they're going to be many many mortgage
holders many many families across the
country who are now even more worried
about paying their mortgage that's on
top of all the other bills and they know
that the government's failed now for 13
years they know the government crashed
the economy last year and what I think
most people want is the government that
rolls up its leaves gets involved
doesn't say well it's nothing we can
really do about it and does as the late
parties suggested which is require
lenders to take the steps not rely on
their mortgage holders to come forward
because I think many will be reluctant
to do that require the lenders to put in
place proper measures to Shield them or
support them
so quite interesting what we've heard
from the chancellor today and I'm sure
there will be many people including
probably Martin Lewis who also met the
chancellor quite recently the money
saving expert guy if you like
um he has suggested windfall tax on big
Banks and the labor party have put
forward their own suggestions on what
should be done to support people through
this period so it'd be interesting that
how those people react to What has been
put forward by the chancellor today and
of course pressure as well on the Prime
Minister and the Chancellor from their
own benches lots of conservative MPS
grumbling about first of all the bank of
England's role in all of this saying
that they haven't acted quickly enough
but also pressure mounting to put in
more support for people going through
financial difficulties and potentially
facing repossessions of course the
context of all this is the politics a
general election coming up and real
concern uh particularly on the
conservative benches that this could
cost them big when it comes to the next
general election the political challenge
for the chancellor and the Prime
Minister and that's what this meeting
was about today and the announcement
that we've had subsequently is to try to
convince the public they've got this
under control they know what they're
doing and that these measures that have
been announced do in the end provide
that safety net that people will
desperately need over the coming months
and years